[Music]
well you guys
speaking of nevada it's nevada i'm just
kidding
don't ever say like it's pronounced
trash nevada
anyway so this story comes from there
apparently the desert yeah from
henderson
my brother that's south of the nevada
vegas yeah so there is this viral video
that came out of there that was taken in
a target
you guys have an idea i love target i've
heard of town i've heard of target
do you have you heard of this viral
video i've heard of nevada
nevada nevada all right well this video
here
it shows a woman dressed in a wedding
dress
oh i heard about it and here we go
and she's a ghost yes girl does she
start dancing
no she does not here we go
they got married in target really
no he's walking down the aisle
we're getting married right now or i'm
leaving i'm not
like if you don't marry me this second i
brought the pastor
she has to oh my god what the [ __ ] hi
guys
she asked the employee you know like
we're getting married now or like it's
over
is this a prank this is for real huh
yeah
we can't talk about this outside i'm
shaking
i'm shaking he's shaking you mean the
she just walked into an employee and
forced them out she was like [ __ ] or get
off the pot
[ __ ] yeah so i'll tell you what
she said what in the world is happening
we're gonna get married
right now so she says you put this ring
on my finger two years ago
it's time to do it or get out oh i
brought emily she's my bridesmaid
we're getting married now or i'm leaving
all the workers her husba
the fiancee that's
apparently what this story is about is
it can we talk about this outside
yeah he ends up saying could someone
have told me
oh that's what he said oh that's so
[ __ ] funny
i mean two years is a long time dude
yeah to be engaged but this was a big
joke right
but like uh one one year of the two
years you can't really blame
the the guy really like they're we're in
a pendant yeah
a lot of people have to put their well
david's been engaged for a while now
yeah years almost two years no just a
year i thought it was spring time of
last year we're getting scared she's
gonna come
i'll see springtime pretty soon
[ __ ] hold on a year and a half
this was serious like she was mad well
that's the thing i don't know because
she got up in her get up and all this
you shouldn't get married
i don't know for sure i gotta tell you
guys i don't know for sure if this is
real or if it's fake i tried looking up
for some more info as of today
there has not been any more info oh good
though she got the pastor she's in the
dress
like she's like about to marry him in
that target
outfit you're in a target what pastor
would be down to go to a target a funny
one it reminds me of that show trigger
happy though you ever seen that show
oh they would do random pranks like that
and they had really good actors and it
seemed
like legit and the person would be like
i don't know you and he's like
you know me you put this ring on my
finger like that oh that's good
the best one is with the ones where they
have a piece of [ __ ] come in
and then you wait for the people to
defend them what's that one show
do you know that it's actually about
good human uh interaction oh what'd you
do
yeah that shit's [ __ ] tight dude it
got me mad
yeah it's like a goddamn people not
doing anything there'll be like chinese
people eating and somebody yo go
get out of here wuhan and then they wait
for somebody to stand up his name is
steve
you should treat people this way yeah
and then they start crying at the end i
just want people that like it
and i'm crying like that too oh [ __ ]
what's going on oh [ __ ] you need to lean
back stop breaking everything
no sorry all right so something to
mention though
is that particular target did
say that the man in the red shirt was
not a target employee so it could
be a prank kind of thing like it could
be like a setup kind of thing
i hate that i just don't know what the
result is yet like is this
like trying to advertise some [ __ ]
because remember in the past we've done
stories where they create like a whole
scene and it turns out it's like this
marketing
ploy for some other [ __ ] i don't
know yet what this could
be exactly what it is it's a target
because if it doesn't work there then
it's already a setup it's i don't want
to deal with it anymore you just ruined
the magic
yeah yeah i'll [ __ ] dare you yeah but
let's just pretend it is real though
how [ __ ] nuts is this you shouldn't
give an ultimatum like that
marry me right now [ __ ] yeah imagine
what you're married
not romantic no i'd feel romantic if
someone comes up to me in a dress in the
middle of target
while i'm stalking someone and forces
you to marry them
you don't ask them what if it was like
here someone
came in with the pastor while you're at
work at j.k
that'd be crazy maybe because of i mean
like
she got proposed to during jk news yeah
and it's just what we do
i was like oh yeah you know like like
it's like almost like
a skit or like we're making a tick tock
video yeah no but what if it was like
this situation where it's like if i take
myself you've been together
for this long and you put this ring on
my finger for this long
damn i would not i would run too i would
move out
i'll be like you keep the ring yeah i
think i'll move away
completely you know i'll fake my death
the national
average for uh engagement ring is pretty
pretty low what is it
i think it was like two to three grand
for an engagement i might actually be
shooting a little high i mean you guys
could
put fact check me on that one but it's
actually pretty [ __ ] low who drives
it up the la market people well i think
because we're also confusing like income
all across the united states right yeah
and then on top of that i think the
average
not household income but individual
income is in the 30 000 range for a
majority of people so household income
is in the sixth
sixty thousand sixty nine thousand or
something like that i think individually
is thirty five yeah you have to go by
state
to get like a more that's why it's more
affordable in other states because
their average median income is less yeah
so when people want to spend like an
absorbent amount on the ring i i was
like
looking up rings for mario i was like
well how much should i spend i was like
the next 2k
[ __ ] i'm good what was marielle
saying like you better give me one of
those she doesn't care i could give her
a cracker jackering it wouldn't that
matter i get so [ __ ] on that when i
google like what's the average cost of
blank because i've been look trying to
renovate stuff in our house yeah and i'm
like
what's the average cost of replacing a
bathtub and it's like two hundred
dollars
yeah not in l.a i call someone and
they're like that's four thousand
dollars i'm like what the [ __ ]
yeah it's two hundred dollars in the
[ __ ] yeah yeah
it's different i i went undercover so
like you know for our vegas house like i
just want to see how much construction
is over there
yeah so i already have my digital render
cover i believe
online undercover so i took my trench
coat sorry if any of you guys watch but
i had to undercover your ass cause i'm
trying to figure out the prices over
there
um i took the digital renderings that i
have for the house over here
and i would dm like a bunch of like
jill's face look i'm like what is he
about to say
i would dm a bunch of vegas contractors
and i'm like hey i just got a house over
here
could you guys give me a quote for
something like this and everything was
from 50 to 70 percent not cheaper
it's the the cost of it is 50 to 70 of
what i paid
minus 30 just because minimum wage is
just lower like everything is just lower
so the cost of everything is just lower
and i'm like
this is crazy yeah that's what my friend
that lives
in vegas was saying that everything's
way cheaper to
remodel and stuff but y'all only live in
los angeles
i've been living here all my life
atlanta dude
but you're not even in sacramento you
live out here i know i love it out here
though
i like sacramento better than aleya to
be honest
i love both i grew up in sacramento it's
great yeah you little [ __ ]
pick one how about hawaii though oh
hawaii
i got the right reaction that's the best
consensus that's
the best of the best no you like desert
you don't like water don't go there
without the [ __ ]
island fever he likes cheap in my in my
life right now
no i got island fever now hail and i'm
in a house
island i would in the state of emergency
like
picture the pandemic happens you can't
just fly to california to see your
family
or you can't like just on a whim go
driving somewhere i think i would feel
like a little
trap trapped yeah that would be kind of
cool because i'm right next to japan in
korea
so it's like right over there you could
take a sailboat and come
to the mainland in 30 days pacific is
starting today
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] a sailboat dog
the pacific is rough i watched a video
of a guy that
had a 27 foot sailboat and he went from
la to maui and then from maui he went to
seattle you got to really plan your food
that's too [ __ ] scary
i know the seasickness yeah dirty do you
get seasick i do
i think just seeing no land would cause
an anxiety attack
really i would freak the [ __ ] out in the
middle of the ocean for 27 [ __ ] days
i don't see land i'm like it was by
himself
this fall oh
[Laughter]
the the bird's just in the middle of the
ocean no when you're closer to shore
there's like birds that are no i just
picture like in the middle of the ocean
a bird just came over it's like yeah
what are you doing here
it's like what the [ __ ] was this footage
rocky as [ __ ]
because in the middle of the ocean it's
like this he had a gopro and he had a
sailboat no just like a regular vlog
and it was like the most chillest dude
ever damn you gotta be chill to handle
that
did somebody get lost at the sea and the
only way they could live was drinking
like fish blood
oh my god i just saw a video that like a
lady was
was missing for two years yeah we did
that but she wasn't
in the ocean for two she was just
floating she was she threw herself in
the ocean because she was depressed
and she was in there for like eight
hours or something but not
not three days oh that's hilarious she
tried to drown but she just floated yeah
i think it was a jk title i read
yeah i read that story okay but yeah man
i can't imagine being lost to see that's
insane
no i just i need to see land i need that
type of security even when we go out on
those like
hawaii yachts seeing land makes me feel
comfortable yeah
once it gets all blue like i went i went
deep sea fishing
i was like oh [ __ ] ain't no layer at all
you don't feel like a pirate though
no i don't want to be on a boat with you
because that one time we got on that
catamaran yeah they were like we went on
a cruise too
yeah i know i don't want to be on a boat
with david he brings bad luck we're only
going on boats together
that's it we're not friends anymore how
did you like the cruise that we went on
it was just well the cruise just made me
feel like i was gonna die because it was
just it felt very old
i hate i hate because like cruises are
or two things right
party cruises or it's [ __ ] geriatric
as [ __ ] there's nothing
there's no in-between yeah but watching
old people dance to ymca was so funny
it was cute and then we did karaoke how
many times can you watch that
i could watch that every night okay you
know what was tight though when we were
playing basketball and the boat would
sway and then the hoop would go diagonal
you shoot and then the the thing moves
what
i was on a cruise and someone was
choking in the restaurant like they had
to do a heimlich maneuver and they
passed out and they were like on the
floor and stuff oh it was pretty scary
were they swaying well he was kidding me
the food on cruises is really good
because if you do the all-inclusive
package it's the buffet but the
restaurants are so
cheap you get like a four course meal
for 20 bucks i didn't even know that
ridiculous
should have paid
[Music]
you